nous voulons une majorité il faut bien
additionner les électeurs et les
électrices ces mêmes voix qui n'ont pas
pu s'additionnaient la présidentielle on
l'a vu deux fois de suite 1 il a manqué
des voix pour que la gauche et les
écologistes soient qualifiés en 2017 il
a manqué des voix pour que la gauche et
les écologiste ou les écologistes soient
qualifiés en 2022 donc nous parlons
d'une coalition qui puisse agréger les
coalitions c'est un accord de
gouvernement c'est autour et avec c'est
pas derrière il sema derrière bon bah on
va revenir s'il c'est très important aux
anciens c'est d'accord d'une personne
qui ont pu voter yannick jadot et j'en
fais partie
doivent pouvoir se dire cette coalition
ça n'est pas juste l'union populaire et
tout le monde le comprend puisqu'il
s'agit d'additionner les
ânes hidalgo et je sais qu'en ce moment
les discussions continuent avec le parti
socialiste et après cette émission je
les rejoins nous espérons finaliser un
accord s'étant vu yannick jadot
législatif alors yannick jadot je peux
vous le dire il a annoncé il ne sera pas
candidat aux législatives il est député
européen et je vous avoue que en vrai on
est très content de son travail
labarrère les socialistes vous parlez
des communistes vous parlez moins des
trotskistes et du npa vous négociez en
ce moment même avec le npa c'est
beaucoup moins avancés voilà je vais pas
là pour le coup c'est vraiment ce serait
vraiment historique je vais pas c'est
sûr que moi pour le coup j'ai pu
s'échanger avec fabien roussel et
olivier faur
notamment sur tous les aspects
programmatiques et 7 l'importance
vraiment de cette coalition pour
additionner les électorats géographie
enjeux communs avec le nbaer j'ai pas eu
cet échange encore avec le npa je vais
être très franc vous venez sur moi pour
moi l'accord il est déjà exceptionnel si
nous parvenons à organiser à 4 c'est à
dire l'union populaire de jean luc
mélenchon
les europe ecologie les verts ou les
écologistes que j'ai l'honneur de
représenter le parti socialiste avec
fort le parti communiste a une ligne
rouge inventaire n'est pas une ligne
rouge pour vous moi je peux pas faire
deux lignes rouges sur les organisations
nous avons adopté un programme
extrêmement ambitieux climat justice
sociale l'égalité femmes-hommes
autonomie de la jeunesse la combattre
cette réforme injuste des retraites
le rétablissement des services publics
la biodiversité voyez la règle d'or
climatique lisf climat
cif et la création de centaines de
milliers de places à lille et invite
toutes les forces mayrand tout et
j'appelle les différentes forces qui
pourraient se retrouver dans ce voyez
que l'idée c'est pas juste un accord
électoral on projette un espoir voilà
nous disons le 12 et 19 juin regardez
pas les tig la majorité possible vous
vous retrouvez dans cette ambition de ne
pas subir cinq ans d'inaction climatique
et le cassage
si l'accord si l'accord il en demeure à
vous et la france insoumise et que ça ne
fonctionne pas avec le parti
est-ce qu'il est toujours valable est-ce
que vous irez tout seul avec elle à la
france insoumise ou est-ce qu'il est
caduque pour concevez comme un ensemble
mot c'est une coalition et nous disons
et d'ailleurs c'est le communiqué commun
que nous avons signé avec la france un
semis d'hier qui dit pour être efficace
évidemment que nous voulons nous donner
tous les moyens tous les moyens pour que
les autres forces puissent se retrouver
dans cette série si vous n'y arrivez pas
parce que vous restez là d'un accord ou
est-ce que l'accord est caduc d'accord
il est valable
si par malheur ça se présente mais c'est
moi je quand j'ai quitté mon chien moi
quand j'ai quitté la table des
discussions pour venir à cette émission
parce que c'est comme ça que ça s'est
passé tout l'après-midi
les insoumis et les socialistes quand
j'ai quitté la table n'y a pas de raison
que ça ne puisse pas
[Musique]